as the security Council was convened
Russia was already signaling it was
about to declare victory in the four
referenda in eastern Ukraine but the
un's political Chief made it clear those
votes had no legitimacy in international
law they cannot be called a genuine
expression of the popular will speaking
to the security Council for the fourth
time since the Russian invasion in
February Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski called for Russia to be kicked
out of all International organizations
including the UN
the implementation of the so-called
crimein scenario and another attempt to
Annex Ukrainian territory will mean that
there is nothing
to talk about with this President of
Russia annexation is the kind of move
that puts him alone against the whole of
humanity Russia's Ambassador Vaseline
nabenzia warned these referenda may not
be the last
now Kiev is being rejected not only by
the people of Crimea and dombas but
Herson and the parisiania region this
process is going to continue if Kiev
does not recognize its mistake and its
strategic errors that this process could
continue after the meeting I got
reaction to that from the U.S ambassador
they did it in 2014 and now they're
doing it again so I have no doubts in my
mind that they will attempt uh to do it
and that's why it's so important that we
stand against this immediately
Ambassador Thomas Greenfield says she
plans to bring a draft resolution
condemning Russia to a vote in the
security Council as early as the end of
this week Russia then would clearly use
its veto but the U.S and its allies are
then planning to bring things to all 193
members of the UN at the general
assembly James Bay's Al Jazeera of the
United Nations